hello everyone I'm Dave joined by its
ammo Hussein hey we hunt some monsters
recently we did and this is your first
experience with monster hunt oh right
yeah the first ones hunter game I've
ever played so I'm really interested in
seeing what you think about it because
it's you're someone who's well-versed in
video games and you're submerged in the
culture of it so you've probably heard
and seen a lot of talk about popularity
of monster hunter both in this in the
West and even more so in Japan and maybe
or one of those people just kind of
looked at you from afar it's always
seemed like like I've always been
interested in it like youngers the
drawers always been like big monsters
massive daft weapons cooking big bits of
meat and a barbecue yeah but I just
never had either the console or the
inclination to jump into it and towards
the end of the series before months tons
of worlds I would talk to people and
they'd be like quite inaccessible and
that kind of turned me off to it as well
so but now all that has changed not only
is it available on all platforms like
ps4 Xbox one and PC you see it but
awesome I think
yeah and it's it's the most streamlined
in onboarding people into the Monster
Hunter experience so it's really easy to
pick up and play now it still has these
intricacies in the way you like outfit
yourself for a mission and accept
missions and things like you know
building clans and that kind of stuff
but the the game actually in how it
plays is very it feels very like much
like a normal action game right yeah it
felt um I mean we are fighting like no
Naga ghonte nehru gig on teh i think and
it's that was the hardest dude in the
demo yeah I felt like I was throwing the
deep end but after a few like easier
hunts I felt like I was slowly getting
to grips with it there that feels like
there's like a lot of layers to it like
there's dozens of weapons each with like
some of them in multiple modes to know
this all the items or the ammo types I
like that that you can change you know
change up your your fighting style by
just switching out your equipment that's
really refreshing to me as someone who I
got a lot of Dark Souls vibes from it so
I went in thinking about builds and
like build your character that way but
instead just like a fancy shooting
Thunder at people but monsters and says
I'm just gonna have this giant Daft
bogan
yeah the depth of it is actually in
familiarizing yourself with your own
characters weapon and the Moose of it
because they have a lot of they don't
have a lot of moves but each of those
moves the way you access them can be
different from weapon to weapon and
there's you know usual things like what
range it's beste and what kind of ammo
you use for example for the guns and and
the other part of it is actually the
monsters themselves are way more
intricate and and kind of exciting than
they initially seem like even the
standard low level monsters those are
kind of like fodder but if you'd like
observe them and fight them and keep on
doing that you start to figure out oh
they behave in certain ways and you can
figure out strategies that work well for
countering there and you know trapping
them and doing things like that so it's
one of those games that really is it's
it's easy to play but it takes a long
time to really really master and you can
never quite become an x-block a super
amazing Masana player you kind of
there's always this element of things
could go wrong at any time that's the
kind of game I like though I like having
that layer of risk I mean you see me
being super inept I'm the guy with the
bow gun and it took me even a while to
just realize that I could just aim the
thing mmm I was kind of trying to use
the lock-on and failing pretty abysmally
at it and then they also gave me like a
metric buttload of ammo so trying to
figure out what the ammo did yeah it was
it was tricky to get to grips with but
like you said like you said at the
surface you can play it like a normal
action game it'll be familiar to you I
think I was just a little bit
overwhelmed in this demo just because it
was literally thrown in at the deep end
yeah so this is the extra mission which
I believe is going to be included in the
upcoming bayar so the rest of that there
were a total of five missions I think it
was but the first five yes because for
or or first three were just the same as
the one that were included in the last
beta so we we did those real quick and
then we went to the neuro gig on teh
mission and this is the dinero gigante
is the kind of flagship monster IG yeah
every monster hunter game has a new
flagship monster you treat him kind of
like the star athletes on a fee for
something but like this is the new and
then you
and they're not talking too much about
him in the marketing or anything because
if they're trying to caught new people
talking about this new monster in really
specific loving detail could be quite
alienating because they like I just
don't really know what this means and
I'm kind of like detached from all this
stuff but this guy is really cool
because firstly you can see he's
impossible so difficult to pin down yeah
like I was using the sword and it was
very and as people who play using those
weapons or know is is they're very slow
so like by the time you've wound up an
attack he's usually gone yeah seems like
I'm out and yeah you only had 15 minutes
for this fight yeah exactly it's very
time and this is this is actually one of
the fights were one of the new additions
the slingshot I think it is is essential
because one of the many functions of
that is you can aggro enemies and kind
of get their attention so it was super
import we didn't do it here because we
weren't a well-oiled machine yeah it was
just me and a couple of other people I
think our team were pretty new as well
yeah we had a we had a couple people who
won one of us who was just straight-up
wasn't playing the one who was the same
situation I was in first month's answer
so but I'm looking forward to like
actually starring it from beginning and
yeah learning my first Monster Hunter
and slowly building up that that skill
set which I think is going to be
important for fighting something like
this and then you also need a mass a
really well-oiled machine of a team as
well so like you could well playing this
I could see how it would be in a few
weeks time when we were when we know
what we're doing like you'd have to so
you can see like the white almost
solidified Kelsey calcified structures
on them that happens when he's kind of
like annoyed I think yeah right and he
becomes more powerful and I believe he's
like I think he sheds them after a while
but like while he's doing that you've
got to quickly hit them and get them off
him otherwise it becomes incredibly
aggressive and they do extra damage so
like when you're playing this properly
we'd all be using our slingshots to kind
of give each other space and agroni and
their gun take over we'd be using traps
better will be using bombs better we'd
all have diverse styles of fighting like
in
you've got a range here I'd probably be
better at using the sword yeah we might
have someone else who's kind of trying
to mantle the kind of monster but if it
felt like such an event I can imagine
just after being in the monster net
world for a while and then coming up
against this it's it's like the pinpoint
of your experience yeah obviously we go
crushed as we saw we kind of we went in
knowing that or illegally we would get
crushed because we got like three lives
and there's when yeah but I'm gonna say
on the record now when this game comes
out we're gonna squat up beat this going
being within at least the first two
months of release there you have it I
think we've got a monster hunter code
two months pass happens like check our
Twitter's or something happens feel free
to call me on it but until then I hope
you enjoy the video
I've been Dave you can find me at a
regular Dave tomorrow I'm at two more H
for more monster hunter world concert
make sure you stay tuned to games for
calm